o olho não
bom dia
an é um pouco nervosa estou habituada a
estar aqui mas não falar normalmente só
no fim agradeço e fugir
vamos ver com uma coisa que o convidaram
para partilhar um pouco da minha viva e
um pouco daquilo que eu faço na maioria
para ser feliz
e para tentar que os outros também à
minha volta sejam flash é isso que eu
vou pagar um cursinho convosco minha
vida você dançar aos quatro anos morava
em lisboa na altura e volta dos meus
nove anos em leiria continua e sempre a
dançar a dança sempre fez parte da minha
vida
na escola não era assim
não foi assim tão baixo
eu sou ética e na minha altura sido
léxico era ser diferente
sentia muita gente frustrada não houve
apoios nas escolas os próprios pessoas
não sabiam como nos podiam apoiar
então muitas das vezes os meus colegas
iam para casa e eu ficava mais uma ou
duas horas a fazer cópias em que deram
duas linhas o que nomeou absolutamente
nada ninguém explicar vá se eu fazia
antes de escrever uma palavra com essa
com dois s
tanto a dislexia continua carro isso
criou uma em nenhuma grande insegurança
e eu achava que não era capaz de fazer
nada que não ia se ninguém na minha vida
a não ser trabalhar com estas coisas
a itália é mais
o painel meio trabalhar então mais tarde
com o aparecimento da internet temos
acesso à internet incluindo sou do tempo
em que se aprende datilografia para
causar uma cartada na máquina e quando
começamos a ir a mais com a internet e
descobri que havia pessoas que eu
admirava bastante e também eram os
léxicos pessoas como o autismo e steve
jobs steven spielberg e muitos outros
isso num momento em que estava um pouco
mais embaixo dava alguma força pensava
se estas pessoas conseguiram ser alguém
conseguiram atingir objetivos na vida e
também quer também quer ser alguém na
minha vida estava cansado na triste e
desanimada com a escola então altura em
que eu tive que optar por uma área ter
que fazer alguma coisa que tirar um
curso e não sei fazer nada sabia dançar
e na altura até mal e e desenhar tentar
entrar na escola superior de dança
orientam que afinal podia ser alguém e
ter jeito para alguma coisa e acho que
eu mais me destacava era a minha
criatividade as coisas loucas que
inventava que o que eu conseguia criar
as minhas colegas mas eu não consegui
mas no final do curso não conseguiu
lidar com tanta opção tantas horas de
trabalho ter que fazer trabalhos
críticos ainda nove wolf então era
máquina elétricas me enganava folha fora
tenha que fazer tudo novo e aquela
pressão que vivia na escola superior e
principalmente competição deixou de
rastos e eu tive
é uma grande opção fiquei mesmo muito
mal
tomara que minha mãe resolveu comprar um
telemóvel do que eu se fosse um jogo mas
que era a única que tinha um telemóvel
da keu's era punk controlar as entradas
e saídas na escola e tentar acompanhar
não porque de imagem
então acho que sou professora tento que
os meus alunos se divirtam ao máximo o
tempo que proporcionará aí os bons
momentos e momentos em que consigam
libertar o deixem para trás a escola
aliás eu digo muitas vezes até os pais
dos meus alunos que obrigações todos nós
temos o trabalho a escola explicações
se nós pudermos aprender algo com bom
ambiente com as gargalhadas à mistura
fantástica
vamos tentar trabalhar assim que
trabalhem muito simples meus alunos e
penso que consiga ter obter muito mais
resultados tendo uma maior proximidade
entre professor aluno e criar que eu do
ambiente que a pessoa sinta falta não
queria dançar é preciso que eu queria
para mim o fim do dia e acho que é muito
importante nos muito esta frase quem
desce mais fez ao longo destes 16 anos
que dá aulas
realmente há pequenas coisas que me faz
lembrar todos os dias que eu consiga
contribuir para a felicidade dos meus
alunos
coisas do gênero a quantia equivale ao
ativo dia toda amarrada nos livros por
farta disto forte a desfilar precisava
mesmo de vídeo contrair estava em ouvir
quer dizer que nós fazemos a diferença
conseguimos criar alimentos para as
pessoas realmente de contraírem a doença
tem essa capacidade de sermos um carinho
nós temos 10 m da nossa pele conseguindo
três nem que seja durante uma hora duas
do que é o nosso mundo ficar fora das
preocupações que temos no dia a dia
não é por acaso que 80% das pessoas sai
à noite sai para dançar e beber um copo
receber dois ou três
agora é correr pior
porque o resto que é a maioria das
pessoas fazem porque suas mãos se juntam
um espaço e ficam no silêncio de um jogo
de xadrez porque não se juntam todas
brasileiras primeira fantástico
engasgavam logo na primária e tem cidade
de derna urina mantendo se atrasar ouvir
música alta e parte técnica dançarina
ter que eu queria e só para nós que
quase anjos nem dá pra falar uns com os
outros e tentou danças o ser humano
precisa muito desse momento que um
pequeno vídeo com uma música que se
enquadra perfeitamente no tema música
todos conhecem em que por trás das
pessoas tão chiques onde as pessoas
podem dançar
acabou e eu sei eu
é complicado eu penso que é um bom
exemplo de que realmente a dança está em
todo o lado nós vemos a dança nas
provisões nos concursos de televisão
flash mob casamentos batizados tanto as
pessoas usam muito a dança como um meio
para se libertarem prestígio tira e e eu
encontrar e se calhar na dança não sou
algo que eu achava que conseguia fazer
mais alguma realizasse e tenta ao máximo
e trabalhar dessa maneira de ajudando os
outros realizar os sonhos de luz e tento
ao máximo que as pessoas se divirtam mas
acho que ainda existe nos dias de hoje
nas escolas e nos empregos é uma grande
lacuna as pessoas não são incentivadas e
isso é uma coisa que eu senti muita
falta de ser incentivada se motivada
para fazer cada vez mais e melhor e
tentou mas sim fazer isso com as pessoas
como o daee principalmente com os meus
alunos desde os 4 anos até aqui os mais
velhos que estiveram aqui no palco e
dançaram tudo bem eu acho que exportaram
tudo bem são as curiosas e existe um
exemplo que eu gosto muito da marca é
preenchido por força positiva porque é
um animal tão grande gigante
se nós vamos tentar ensinar a orca por
força negativo da coisa pode ser corra
muito mal e na primeira oportunidade
estamos imbuídos de uma vez só
isso acontece com o cão ou o golfinho e
hoje também pode acontecer com o ser
humano e tem que acontecer com o ser
humano
ajudamos as pessoas a atingir os
objetivos delas puxando sempre para cima
e motivadas
se está na minha aula e dizer olha está
uma porcaria mas é importante treinar em
espanha tiver melhor voltas
a gente pode até não está assim tão bons
de fantástico a continua dom criem mais
motivação à criança a seguir vai querer
voltar para a fila foi outra vez e fazer
outra vez de fazer talvez até em usar um
desvio total mexes mais e assim que o
que eu acho que surgiu ser trabalhadas
os trabalhos não esquecendo de elogiar o
outro é muito importante a pessoa sente
motivada para fazer a alguma coisa que
tenhamos também tive que um foi forçado
a ativa senti essa necessidade de
procurar um psicólogo
o meu filho também é disléxico e como eu
sofri tanto na escola eu queria saber o
que eu podia fazer mais por ele tentará
ajudar ao máximo para que eu não sentes
o que eu senti então no meio de uma
conversa com o psicólogo 1 eu perguntou
mas então o que faz o que dispara motiva
mais o seu filho sair uma frase é e ver
como é capaz de ir a um teste positivo
estava com mais capaz e ela parou logo
ali conversa ele sim você já está errado
ficar onde estou hoje a crença e erraram
no cabelo elogiar se você que eu vou
elogiar mas também lembrou que o falhou
antes que eu errava e que realmente fez
algum sentido na cabeça tentou mas se
não usar essas palavras não estás a ver
como é capaz
somente isso lembra que a pessoa tenha
falhado antes desta vez acertou ao
mínimo a uma mínima palavra às vezes
maldita
eu estava como estava a pensar que
estava ajudá lo afinal estava lembrá lo
de que eu tenha errado antes e agora fez
mais uma coisa só fantástico boa até
mais cinco para baixo
coisas simples elogiar só o ato acho que
que muito importante
sorria mais vezes tento cada dia será um
dia melhor
tento fazer pessoas felizes há um pouco
de tudo isto o que o que eu disse aqui
vai estar um carro gaga jantar será o
fluence acordar negras e teremos
acordava darmos valor às coisas que
temos a saúde que temos e tentar ser
feliz e cada minuto que passa e tento
passar isso muito o meu filho e brinco
em tvs com ele brinca com ela em
qualquer lado e quer que eu criei ficha
sendo uma criança feliz é que avisa
quando venceu uma
fiquei um pouco eu vou ganhar vou contar
estávamos na caixa de supermercado e meu
filho vira pra mim assim muito alto e
desligado
já disse para não fazer cocô do shell
fiquei com muito medo
osmar muito atrapalhada olhar pra mim
explica que o ano uma brincadeira
lembrarmos os dois aí ia pagar as
compras mas essas coisas que eu tento
passar ao que havia que nós podemos
fazer o que quisermos
não é fazer concorrência é óbvio tempo
passar
o mau tempo que eu seja espontâneo que
se divirta é fazer que é corrido riscos
que a gente compra ainda que árias foi
um espaço comercial era nenhum vou com
meu pai tem 72 anos e quando o ladrão
estava lá olha outro lado não vai
pendurar os concorrentes das compras e
eu se fosse o o meu filho e um geólogo
roleta
mas não como era uma prioridade a
senhora que estava lá a fazer oposição a
ele o prêmio sorriu platinum água e meu
pai também passe muito para mim
tentaremos aproveitar a vida ao máximo
da melhor maneira a fazer aqui uma frase
não cumprida
vou ler rapidamente
só pra constar não ficar aqui as ações
revelam mais do que as palavras e um
sorriso diz goste se fico feliz ao ps
estou contente por vê lo é por isso que
os cães têm tanto sucesso
ficam tão contentes por nos ver quase
saltando para fora da sua pele por isso
naturalmente ficamos contentes por ver
também o sorriso bebé tem o mesmo efeito
em nós foi retirado de um livro de
daniel cara de como fazer amigos e
influenciar pessoas
acho que o fim de 20 anos voltei a ler
um livro em silêncio para ninguém ouvir
e aprender muita coisa neste livro e
isso desde todas essas coisas que já
houve aqui em cima do palco
aquelas gargalhadas dos bbbs que ouvimos
aqui realmente é contagiante
se as pessoas tentarem fazer coisas que
nos conta de em isto vai criar aqui uma
uma bola não é conseguirmos sorrir
outros revoltas nós tínhamos uma
repartição qualquer hora e foi preciso
de ser bom dia ou quase - atendendo a
despachantes ou menos preencher era 10
impressos do corpo rochoso e pelas
filhas casadas ele enfim se inscreva se
fosse jogar uns com sorriso na cara e
serve bem disposta um dia conquistar a
está chata
foi um simpático é que vamos pôr
desarmaram casa das pessoas e isso hoje
atendendo melhor tanto se nosso rio
vamos receber isso revolta que se
esquece a próxima de nós e fazem aquela
festa quase impossível num novo tributo
com uma festa com carinho
no entanto podemos fazer isso com as
pessoas e 1 tenho certeza que não nos
disse nada novo apenas quis partilhar um
bocadinho de que o que eu faço no dia a
dia
há coisas que eu com a minha depressão
deixei de fazer proíbe mesmo fazer eu
não gosto músicas tristes não as músicas
calmas a não ser que a espanha quer
trabalhar
raramente vejo telejornal
fiquei pra chorar e tal só pra vocês
verem
quando eu quando vou a guerra do golfo
com sou eu sou dois dias depois - que
vive no meu mundo fantasioso e é verdade
eu queria uma barreira entre mim e as
coisas que não trazem felicidade e esse
não os quero pra mim nos lavo tento
fazer o máximo de coisas que entraram
pra cima
um puxa para cima e das suas tristezas
parte e olha faça o favor de ser reflexo
fotomotor por fazer esquecer
ó ó